Hey hi I'm not saying you're crazy I ate
something weird I can't fall for a fat
person right now I guess all those awake
that night a girl's gonna be the lead
sports story in the world in the crown
jewels fall TV premieres are headed our
way and so are a whole lot of fresh
faces so we at ET are naming these six
breakout stars who are going to shine
the brightest on your screens this
season but me so I'm just gonna live my
life do my thang yeah maybe you don't
see my thing anymore hmm get ready to
fall head over heels for Tory Anderson
on the CW's rom-com no tomorrow and
Kylie Bunbury completely knocks it out
of the park with her emotional
performance in fox news pitch what the
hell was that today I don't know what is
your problem girl you are I'm a robot in
cleats and I'm not functioning alfonso
herrera will give you chills in the best
way possible on Fox's The Exorcist and
Lucas chill delivers a refreshing twist
on the classic MacGyver tail on CBS tell
me to lose the damn wait Chrissy Mets
will tug on your heartstrings as she
steals each and every scene and NBC's
dramedy this is us and get ready for a
whole lotta laughs from Katie Nixon's
wildly relatable performance in ABC's
American housewife how did you get a
piece of stain on the back of your shirt
I was either wearing it backwards when I
ate the pizza or I'm wearing it
backwards now yeah now all right guys
tweet me the breakout stars you're most
excited to meet this fall and keep it
locked to et online for all the biggest
news on your small screen favorites hi
guys